IT IS A COMPLETE EFFORT TONIGHT
AND THEY NEED TO BE DISCIPLINED
AGAINST THE LEAGUE'S NUMBER 1
POWER PLAY.
LEAGUES HAVE BEEN RERETO NYLAND
HE IS
A MOVE AS   GAME . RIGHT BACK A
HOLL MISSED THE LAST COUPLE OF
GAMES FOR
HELD IN BY WILLIAM KARLSSON.
KARLSSON DID NOT PLAY  IN THE
GAME AGAINST TORONTO EARLIER HE
NOW DADONOV LOOKING TO  WAS TRY
THAT.
GOT A LITTLE LUCKY IT WENT OFF
THE SKATE OF KERFOOT  BUT HE
RECOGNIZED THERE WAS S , FIRST
LEAFS IN NEARLY 7
GOLDEN KNIGHTS HAD ONE SHOT
FROM THEIR TOP TWO LINES IN THT
PRESSURE.
WILLIAM KARLSSON JUST
DELAYED OFFSIDE.
THE LEAFS WILL  CLEAR ONE OUT.
MATTHEWS SCORES.
RIGHT ON HIS WRIST SHOT
A LITTLE ZONE PRESSURE AND PLAY
TO THE SLOT.
THE SHOT
LITTLE HEAT.
PUCK OUT IN FRONT.
KARLSSON  BACKEND AND RIELLY SM
WORK.
IT POPS OUT FRONT AND KARLSSON
, GOOD PATIENTS.
A
HUTTON TO MARCHESSAULT TIPS IT.
DADONOV LEAFS THE CHARGE. Dave:
WRAPPED AILING BY TWO GOALS
>> Shane: WHAT A PLAY.
HE JUST LOSES IT.
ROLLS OFF THE HEEL OF
BRODIE  BUT STONE GETS IT.
HERE IS PIETRANGELO AGAIN.
THOUGHT ABOUT SHOOTING. THE WAY
HE GETS MORGAN RIELLY TO BITE
TO THE OUTSIDE FOR THE PASS.
TO KARLSSON PIETRANGELO.
NOW JANMARK HAD IT TIPPED AWAY
BY NYLANDER  AND JANMARK FOR VG.
FIVE-HOLE.
MAYBE, BLOCK OR JUST COULDN'T
ELEVATE THE PUCK AND IT ROLLED
UP.WANTED.
CAMPBECAMPBELL KEPT HIS STICK D
>> Dave: NYLANDER WITH A CHANCE
TO WIN THE GAME FOR TORONTO.
HERE HE COMES.
THE SCORES .  WILLIAM